welcome to the first
the first one give me anything so to
kick this is a serious special guest dr.
del risin from university of california
davis I've had a 30 seconds to review
this
but I don't built for a long time
probably not that let's not go back that
long Clemson pension kinetics parent
number of years in Pakistan with the
University of Delaware Maryland working
on malaria vectors
berkeley the bakersfield arbovirus field
station who were under grandfather's of
our abilities and he spent probably 20
years there yeah well 25 there and then
five years ago six years ago went to the
University Davis California system
consolidate vector-borne disease to the
Davis campus and was brought there and
now he's the director of the Center for
vector for diseases
probably the largest
so a bill so we have way to bill because
he's only person that I know who has
actually has a grant federally funded
grant study climate change very good one
disease and so here it is going to talk
to us about the effect of our no change
on mosquito or a reverse transmission
okay well thank you for the introduction
and thank you for the opportunity to
come I see a lot of familiar faces in
the room which is kind of nice some of
the faces have changed quite a bit but
kind of recognize them I was fortunate
enough to come here probably was at five
or ten years ago and get the seminar so
I hope some of the slides of change for
the people where the previous one and
giving this talk Maria asked me to talk
about climate change but in thinking
about it it's really hard to divorce for
a complex though no sities all the parts
of the environment and just focus on
climate so I've kind of broadened the
topic and i hope the climatologists or
geographers here will permit me to talk
about other things other than just
specifically climate i also since this
is a climate group i didn't spend a lot
of time talking about what climate is
and what drives it and how all the
physics of climatologists so I thought
I'd present a couple of little
background slides first arboviruses are
a taxonomically diverse group of viruses
the only thing they really have in
common is their transmitted by
arthropods but there are arboviruses
that don't have an arthropod vector and
there are some that don't have a
vertebrate host but there are so you're
a big catch all of viruses most of these
probably originated as tropical zone Oh
Sees and then some such as dengue and
yellow fever have evolved to become
anthro panos these that is transmitted
from human to mosquito to human this is
yellow fever with its
jungle cycle spilling over too intrusive
agriculture then moving into villages
where there's transmitted from human to
mosquito to human all of the viruses
require a host of vector and a pathogen
and these have to come together in time
and space to form a nidus of
transmission and this has to be set
within a permissive environment
obviously if the environment is not
conducive to allow this to occur
transmission is impossible some of the
variability of the environment that I
think are important and I'll talk
briefly about human population growth
landscape alteration and how these have
generated climate change and then the
important of connectivity about all
these then and why on some of the
nuances that are transportation by
people have done to these systems so as
I mentioned there's only no seas become
if the ZOA nautic host is a primate
there's a high probability that a can go
then human mosquito human if the zone
adik host is a bird then most likely it
exploits commensals as these viruses
become more or less urbanized the
evolution teams to be is the complex
from complex cycles and the tropics with
a lot of diversity to more simple
transmission either going from sylvan to
urban or a tropical to temperate
ecosystems the barriers to transmission
that these viruses have to overcome are
rather remarkable when you consider that
they're just little pieces of RNA they
have to overcome very different host
immune systems and also very different
temperature regimens remember that the
arthropods appoint kilo therm so they're
essentially at environmental temperature
whereas when they get into a febrile
crow it can be upwards of 44 degrees
centigrade so there's quite a diversity
of environment that the virus must
maintain the virus also must produce a
sufficient viremia in the come
insular human hosts to infect the Arthur
pod because getting through the innate
immune system is usually dose-dependent
the virus must persist during
unfavorable periods and in the tropics
this can be droughts or dry periods but
in looking outside I got a feeling of
New England you know coming here from
California and temperate winners
certainly are an obstacle to persistence
or they have to be repeatedly it
reintroduced for organization the
vectors and hosts must exploit the
domestic pair domestic environment
including development in containers or
wastewater living in and around homes
and exploiting what lives there for
blood meal sources so these are all
obstacles that the viruses have to
overcome I've been spending the last
decade or so in my life study in West
Nile virus so unexplainably most of the
examples will come from this virus this
is a flavivirus in the japanese
encephalitis zero group it's related to
st. Louis encephalitis which used to be
the one of the higher causes of
infectious and sefa lightest in the US
during the 70's especially in the Ohio
River Basin it's no longer very
prevalent the virus was discovered in
the West Nile district of Uganda and 37
during a fever survey the disease ranges
from in apparent infection the flu like
to neural invasive disease to death
rarely death recently however they've
discovered that individuals that are
both asymptomatic and febrile can
develop possible chronic kidney
infarction and this considering there
may have been over 2 million Americans
infected with West Nile this has a
strong possibility as this sort of
unappreciated complication there's
epidemics have occurred initially in
Upper Egypt than South Africa
in the 50s in the Mediterranean there
were intrusions Minh ein TS and then it
jumped over the pond in 1997 leading to
the largest epidemic in the in the 2000s
the when you think about the virus
coming from the tropics coming to New
York City and then spreading
coast-to-coast within four years and
then from Canada to Argentina it's just
really remarkable that this virus has
got around so quickly and been quite so
successful estimating the CDC estimates
there's been over 30 there's been over
30,000 confirmed cases and this
translates into about it based on this
sort of a pyramid into over two million
Americans infected as I mentioned the
virus came out of Uganda spread in the
50s to India down into South Africa and
to Upper Egypt and then in the 90s over
here there was some thought that je
might provide a barrier coming into Asia
but recently they've suggested that it
may also be in Asia so one of the things
with the environment to think about at
least it struck me when I was putting
this together that in my lifetime the
Earth's population is trebled going from
2.5 to 7.5 billion people that's a whole
lot for one generation to absorb I think
and with it of course is the the need
for resources and and the and the effect
of acquiring these resources has had on
the planet the there is geographical
differences in the growth rates and the
country's here in light green are the
ones that have the highest growth rates
but not necessarily the highest
densities when you look at densities
population densities are highest in
India Asia and Europe and these areas
have low densities but high growth rates
another thing that's happened just
recently is for an last year
the first time the demographers estimate
that more than half of the world's
population lives in cities so no longer
we worried about agricultural problems
we're now having to focus more and more
on urban problems and this is perhaps
what we're thinking of now for disease
transmission is certainly a little
easier and this doesn't matter where
you're living whether in the world
Africa Asia all over that more than half
of the population now lives in cities so
what in fact is Arthur pod borne
diseases have on all this well it's kind
of hard to put it to get a case study
but in 1945 the death rate in Sri Lanka
was 22 per thousand and that was with
very very high malaria transmission in
46 they brought in a DDT program
eliminating the almost eliminating the
vectors and malaria dropped sharply
after nine years the death rate was 10
per thousand by 2006 only six per
thousand by the decline has not been
shown in the birth rate so when all this
comes down to is that the annual growth
rate is still about 1.3 percent per year
and at this rate the population is
scheduled to double in 53 years so with
just eliminating a disease like malaria
can have a remarkable effect long-term
on demography and if you look back at
those countries that we showed earlier
that have the highest population for
capita growth rates these are also the
countries that we're targeting with roll
back malaria and other health programs
and we'll be facing the same situation
with the eliminating the burden of
disease I think in the future well as I
mentioned more humans require more
resources this is the percent of forest
cover loss estimated heat by these
people in this five year period is I was
surprised to see the US as the leader
this is where I was living for a long
time right here in Bakersfield this is
the southern San Joaquin Valley of
California so in a hundred years it went
from a sort of intermittent wetland salt
marsh grass environment to right now
it's irrigated agriculture towns and
cities with Bakersfield has gone up an
order of magnitude and number and same
with Fresno there's now believe it or
not 800,000 people living in Bakersfield
and about 1.3 million in in Fresno this
corridor is also with this change is an
increased human density and is some of
the warmest areas in California and this
is also where we see our corridor of
West Nile transmission right up the
Central Valley all this change in the
environment and urbanization results in
urbanized heat Islands that's been well
described this I didn't have a picture
for Bakersfield this is New York City
and this is the vegetation pattern and
this is the heat pattern with the hotter
areas being or light color so there are
pockets of cooler areas that correspond
to vegetation so eliminating the
vegetation increases the temperature
another factor that urbanization occurs
is that it decreases a bee and richness
with increased land heterogeneity you
get an increase in in avian richness but
with development housing maturity and
distance to natural areas you get
decreases this is also relates to
transmission of West Nile where you wind
up having a decrease in West Nile
transmission as a function of the number
of non passer II and species present
this is because the that's only the
passerines are the best hosts for the
virus this is the log
this is logged viremia serum viremia and
these are days post-infection by
different orders of birds you can see up
here where for the passerines we're
looking at at 10 to the 10 or higher
whereas if you look at chickens we're
down here at 10 to the 2 this is
important because the very me is
directly related to how infectious these
birds are for mosquitoes will show that
later on summary then for the human
environmental change population growth
is declining but the number of people
seem to be increasing the trends in hit
and human distribution are from rural to
urban there's high connectivity
urbanization tends to increase host
densities of humans and commensals
decreases diversity increased habitat
and density for commensal species and
increase then the possibilities of human
mosquito contact and then alters climate
change will climate affects all
components of the transmission cycle the
vector the virus as well as the host and
their demography is what drives the
efficiency of and behaviors what drives
the efficiency of transmission climate a
sort of determines the rates especially
temperature there are scales of climate
variability to think of and that the
short-term variability is what we
normally think of as weather
intermediately we think of cycles like
El Nino or the Southern Oscillation and
long term we think of as this trend for
global warming in parallel with the
increase in the human population curve I
showed before there's pretty much an
increase in carbon dioxide the slope is
pretty parallel to the other as well as
an increase in global temperatures the
some pretty smart guys doing a bunch of
models have projected this
up to the next millennium and all of the
models show an increase in temperature
and the range is pretty wide though
trying to predict what's going on almost
a hundred years in the future and of
course then there's some other data that
may be more substantial so climate
change we is there is an increase in
greenhouse gases warming temperature
this tends to be not equally distributed
and tends to be greatest in northern
latitudes there's also cycles in this
long-term trends precipitation I'm not
going to talk about too much but there
is increased in floods and droughts
there seems to be a variable effect in
the US which some areas getting weather
wetter and others dryer we're having a
prolonged drought in the southwest which
people are trying to tie in to climate
change water effects mosquito habitats
but it's a two-edged sword too much
water washes them out too little water
they don't have any breeding habitat for
urban mosquitoes a little bit of drought
is pretty good because everybody at
least in California turns on the lawn
sprinklers and we get curb drizzle into
the catch basins that all just great for
mosquitoes just enough for them but out
drawing them out and they're refreshed
every day because everybody has got
their sprinklers on a timer we're also
looking at sea surface rise and storm
extremes but I'm not going to have time
to go into these so what is the impact
of increasing temperature on arbovirus
transmission well at alter that it
alters most of the factors related to
transmission this can be shown by the
vectorial capacity equation speeds up
mosquito population growth shortens the
overwintering period lengthens the
transmission season obviously these are
the same alters pathogen and vector
distributions in latitude and elevation
so this is the transmissions equation or
vector
capacity equation from Garrett Jones
this is not very new this actually are
the factors the entomological components
of the old ross macdonald malaria model
the ones that I've shown in red are
influenced by temperature and include
mosquito host biting rate and the
duration of the gaana trophic cycle a P
is the probability of survival that is
how long the mosquitoes will live and n
is the duration of the extrinsic
incubation period or how long it takes
from them being infected until they can
transmit so for mosquitoes or hold on
metabolism sex and they lay eggs go
through a larval and pupil stage and
then emerges adults this this duration
of each generation is directly related
to temperature and if you take the
inverse of the duration and plot it as a
rate function of temperature you can
develop a degree day model which 4qx to
our stylist has a threshold of about six
degrees centigrade below which the
larvae will not develop and it takes a
total of about 270 degree days after
they emerge they Harden take sugar mate
and then we'll host seek and the timing
between when it takes a blood meal until
it digests it and lays eggs and comes
back and refeeding on atrophic cycle if
you take this duration the same thing
calculate a rate you can fit a linear
degree day model again here the
thresholds at five and the degree days
are 33 measuring the extrinsic
incubation period as a function of
temperature is a little more difficult
what we what we had done is rear the
mosquitoes in the insectary feed them on
a blood virus mixture hold them at
different times at different
temperatures anesthetize them and take
them apart
and plug their proboscis into a two but
they're still alive at this point
believe it or not then they will
involuntary expectorate and you can then
collect virus in the tube and see if
they could transmit or not so by testing
the bodies you can tell if they're
infected and testing the expectorate you
can see if they transmit and we usually
do this on a V Rosell plaque assay these
little holes of the plaques each one of
ours so as I meant I'm sorry I thought
you had a question so as I mentioned the
proportion infected is a direct function
of the tighter of the host and these in
our experiments the we didn't feed them
on pledges we fed them on birds and got
a variable response though then we then
held them at different temperatures 14
18 22 and on these points are days that
we took out 25 of them and soft they
were how much virus was in them this is
the amount of virus and the body over
time and as as the temperature became
hotter not only did they that the virus
grow quicker but it also grew to
slightly higher titers if we took the
time till fifty percent of them were of
the infected individuals could transmit
we would then have points along this
line which we could turn this this
duration into a rate and plot it again
as a degreed a model so we were able to
develop a degreed a model of about a
hundred and eighty degree days with the
minimum threshold of 14 degrees for
transmission this is the actual duration
and time as a function of temperature
they were incubated at so how does
temperature then affect transmission
well the gonna trophic cycles become
shorter as a function of temperature but
the time the duration of the extrinsic
incubation period decreases in a much
faster rate at about where this long
lines where the extrinsic incubation
period becomes less than two gonna
trophic cycles is where transmission is
most efficient so develop a metric
that's temperature driven we've came up
with a very simplistic as bytes per
transmission or the ratio of the gaana
trophic cycle duration over the
extrinsic incubation period to put this
in yes sir mosquitoes well I about the
mortality well I didn't I took that
slide out this morning okay but so they
do and if you plot the decrease in
survivorship over time you get an
exponential decrease but the the
extrinsic incubation period shortening
makes up overcompensates for this so
transmission occurs so much earlier in
life there are theoretically more
individuals alive to transmit when it's
hotter but you're right the that does
cut back on the longevity especially if
you work like we did down an imperial
valley where it's a 120 degrees in the
summer they don't live too long but the
virus can go through in almost four or
five days down there anyway this is data
from Kern County this is the actual
average daily temperature there in each
month and this is the duration of the
extrinsic incubation period from the
degree day model this is the duration of
the of the first and second gonna
trophic cycles so when this when this
decreased where they could transmit in
less than two cycles this is when the
infection rates which by the blue bars
and the mosquitoes really took off so
this this relationship here we feel or
the number of bytes per transmission is
really very key to when you have most
efficient virus transmission we also
have been working with David Hartley
from Georgetown and he and Chris Barker
put together a
istic model until I'm blaming these guys
so you want to ask me to any
mathematical questions so these this is
three levels of host competence a very
good host a moderate host and a poor
host as well as it's driven by
temperature the most important thing is
the actual estimates of are not over
time during the years when West Nile
came to California this is 2003 through
2009 this is driven by actual
temperature surfaces for California the
red lines are not and the black lines
are the this T value so as T drops again
down to around two bytes per
transmission are not goes way up in the
very hot areas of California like the
Coachella Valley in the cooler Central
Valley well relatively by your standards
it's still hot but it's a lot cooler
than Coachella Valley and here as you
notice these these bars are the Sentinel
chicken zero conversions when these
occurred and notice there was a lot
every year in Coachella sparser in
Sacramento and almost none along the
coast and that shows we never really got
very efficient bytes per transmission
and this area California has had almost
no virus activity since West Nile came
another way of looking this this is
during the introduction into the Central
Valley the the little black dots are
positive chicken flocks than the gray
ones are negative flocks this is bytes
per transmission color-coded the hot
areas in late June had the earliest
virus activity then in the Central
Valley they had a virus activity here
and here and then eventually throughout
the valley later in the summer as this
as everything heated up so trying to use
bytes per transmission as a metric to
look into the future since this is a
climate change talk we do have estimates
from University of California San Diego
for California surfaces and what we did
is took those temperature projections
into the into a 50-year future and tried
to see how it would affect bytes per
transmission well the hot areas the
California had absolutely no change
because it's already hot enough for
transmission all the time most mostly
but the areas along the coast and into
LA basin became especially more
efficient and these are with the areas
that are expected to have the highest
degree of impact from warming if they do
warm as we project another way of
thinking a temperature is at the
northern boundaries of transmission this
is data from Canada the this is in their
surveillance program they had a major
epidemic of West Nile virus in 2007
centered in Saskatchewan of all places I
mean for an out of Africa Uganda virus
to have an outbreak in Saskatchewan so
to mind-boggling they've never had for
example st. Louis epidemics and saying
Saskatchewan they've had western equine
which replicates better at cooler
temperatures but with you look at the
temperatures you can see this is there
the dark line is their 50-year normal
the red line is my 14 degree centigrade
guesstimate of the minimal replication
threshold and this is 2007 if you notice
that it's almost five degrees 10 degrees
centigrade warmer that summer on average
so this is really and the transmission
season was extended from barely having
two or three months above the minimum to
having almost six months so that's why
they had an epidemic that year because
the virus could replicate earlier in the
year there were probably more mosquito
generations and the whole thing just
snowball they had a
similar outbreak in 2003 but the rest of
the years which were more normal
temperatures they they didn't have much
in the way of virus activity at all so I
just had some thoughts about New York
City which I thought were least
interesting to me and why did the virus
come and how did it get to be so
successful and i'm sure you guys like
ted that have been thinking about this a
lot more than me probably have better
ideas but well so the virus came from
israel there was a single mutation at
the NS 249 position that imparted high
virulence for american crows so the
virus that came to New York had already
had this mutation and it was able to
really replicate and kill crows at an
alarming rate other some of the other
lineages and other variants without this
mutation don't kill crows at the same
high rate that the virus we have does
similar strains with this mutation of
cause localized outbreaks in Europe and
Russia and Israel before and there's a
nice paper by heroine Brault describing
this the vector that is our urban vector
QX pipiens well this was a introduction
as well this or this VAR this mosquito
evolved in the ethiopian region and was
sometime introduced into north america
so you've got the an African virus and
an African vector that were sort of
introduced probably during the sailing
ship error interestingly this urban
species was able to herb overwinter a
temperate latitudes and this may have
provided the mechanism for the virus to
be able to persist and John Anderson
who's in the audience has done some
exquisite experiments showing exactly
how this can occur in a remarkably
efficient manner the urban hosts that
are here we also the Brits didn't want
to miss their house sparrows so the they
used to be English sparrows when I was a
kid because they introduced them into
Europe as well as the star
elings and some other birds that we
probably wish they hadn't but so now you
have an urban host and a from the old
world with an African vector and an
African virus interestingly that the
native birds the urbanization has
allowed the expansion of a lot of urban
birds I think like American robins and
out west we have house finches that
exploit the same para domestic
environment and there they were
introduced in the east coast I guess
they're doing pretty good the mycoplasma
hasn't taken them out yet they're
rebounding I somebody's given me the
wave here in the audience the virus has
dead end host but originally when the
virus came there were no vaccines no
drugs and no naturally acquired immunity
so it was a virgin soil epidemic and
there was disbanded infrastructure New
York had done away with a lot of the
arbovirus programs that have been in
place for quite a while and we're very
famous for really classic studies on
eastern equine and these had been
disbanded not to about five years before
it came also that summer when the virus
was first discovered this was supposedly
the hottest summer in New York City
history according to records from
Central Park and so this this I think
certainly didn't hurt obviously if the
virus was introduced in December it
probably wouldn't have taken hold but
coming being introduced some time into
this area of an extraordinarily hot
summer probably with higher mosquito
counts because of it probably contribute
to the sex successful invasion this is
just some pictures of the where the
passer domesticus is now the circum
global species moved around by man we
have a lot of them in California this is
the distribution of the
of the the vectors also coast to coast
this is the some of the other players
this is the house finch that i think is
critical in a lot of parts of California
it's very abundant in the Central Valley
but it's now distributed over the East
Coast as well this is our main mosquito
out west key alekstar salas and it has a
large distribution but it's really in
these areas in here and the central
plains that it's important it's
important to notice that this mosquito
also gets up and to canada because it
tolerates cold a little better than the
pipiens complex so another indication
that these birds are important this is
the is the impact of their immunity on
virus transmission then this is these
red lines are the sero prevalence in
house finches and house sparrows in Los
Angeles and this is during the first
year this is the maroon bars are dead
birds and the blue are human cases and
during 2003 when the virus first came
there was very little detection in 2004
and exploded into a large outbreak of
human cases and huge numbers of dead
crows where they were I mean there were
there were parks where the lawnmower man
had to actually mow around the cadavers
so there were all these little Tufts of
grass marking the locations of dead
crows that were just they were just
everywhere what is interesting to me is
that when the antibody in the house
finches and house barrows got upwards of
about twenty-five percent it just shut
off and the outbreak just they didn't do
any aerial spraying they just did more
larval control but once that antibody
rate got high and there was deep
population of the crows concurrently
that outbreak just subsided rather
rapidly and this this is over time this
is the West Nile neuroinvasive cases and
this is the same antibody this is these
two species combined and as over time
you'll see a decrease in this antibody
as they as the hatching year birds
replace the dying immune birds and when
it gets down to below about ten percent
then we had another outbreak and then
this subsided and then got down below
ten percent and we had another outbreak
in 2011 so it seems like the herd
immunity in these two species is very
critical as well as the depopulation of
the crows we did some blood meal
analysis work and about and just like
you found in Orange County most of the
most of the mosquitos the the vector
mosquitoes feed primarily on these two
species crows are I think are also
important although finding mosquitoes
that have bitten the crow has been a bit
of a problem but if you look at the
distribution of virus cases in Los
Angeles these are the these are
cat-scans that SAT scans statistics and
the the dark circles are human cases the
the dashed lines are clusters of dead
corvids and the size of the circle is
the incidence of human infection if you
in summary only about forty one percent
of the LA population resided within the
clusters but seventy-five percent of the
cases lived within these clusters of
dead birds and the incidents per
thousand within was 5.9 as opposed to
1.3 this was also shown in the infection
rates and mosquitoes being eight per
thousand within and only about two per
thousand out what's interesting is that
in imperial
Coachella Valley they don't have any
corvids and they've yet to have a really
major outbreak although there's a lot of
enzootic transmission and there's a lot
of people that look like me a lot of old
people go there to retire and so these
are the people that have the highest
clinical disease and so you would if
there was a lot of transmission you'd
expect to speak see a lot of sick old
people we just haven't seen the cases
and there's hardly any corvids here at
all up in the Bakersfield area we have
mostly scrub jays and these tend to be
territorial and as such we don't really
see a clustering of cases as we did in
Los Angeles more back to temperature
this is the distribution of human cases
last summer so after years of sort of
having a little fade out of the epidemic
last year was a resurgence back to
probably the incidence of human
infection that was similar to 2003 based
on neural invasive cases but when I keep
referring to neuro invasive disease
because the physicians are not readily
testing fee for febrile cases so total
cases don't really reflect activity they
reflecting physician interests and
having tests done the neural invasive
cases however if you have someone coming
to a hospital with neuro invasive
disease the docs usually want to figure
out why this person is so sick and they
usually get tested not always we did a
study of ER admissions in California
recently and about only one out of five
or getting tested but somehow the docs
are you testing the right people because
we tested the other eighty percent and
they're not getting in there were very
few cases they missed but so that's
story still sort out on that this is the
temperature anomaly this is the
temperature of 2012 compared to
that's nineteen fifty to ninety five
long-term average and you can see that
it was almost three degrees centigrade
warmer in the Midwest and this is where
most of the cases where the epicenter
from last summer was in Dallas Texas and
they had about a third of the nation's
cases California unfortunately ranks
second with about 500 cases this summer
one of the things that we're talking
about with anthropogenic change is the
adjustable mortgages in the housing
market have had a remarkable effect on
West Nile and mosquitoes and this is
data from Kern County from 2006 going
into the housing crash of 2007 and you
notice there's about a three hundred
percent increase in the numbers of
notice of delinquency and notices of
state sales in Kern County concurrently
then people walked away from homes and
the swimming pools and this is what they
turned out look looking like and they're
just great aquariums for growing
mosquitoes this is a shot of big an
aerial image of Bakersfield in which I
counted forty two pools seven of them
which of which are about were probably
looking like this and interestingly when
we collected mosquitoes out of the pools
the rural mosquito culex tar solace that
moved into town to exploit this habitat
because more than half of the mosquitoes
coming out of the pools where the where
the better rural vector concurrently in
2007 there was a three hundred percent
increase in West Nile cases in
Bakersfield that was directly related I
think to these bad swimming pools and
the increase of mosquito numbers so in
summary West Nile is a zoonosis it's
amplified among birds and mosquitoes and
it's their ecology and demography that
is most important for outbreaks because
humans are dead end
a lot of the work is done with numbers
of human cases but it doesn't really
show the amount of virus activity that's
really in an area but rather how exposed
people are and how readily they're being
diagnosed by physicians urbanization has
had an important effect on this virus
because I think right now for most of
the papers I've read us essentially a
suburban urban problem and it's not
something that you go out and leave your
house and go fishing to catch you go in
the backyard and have a barbecue and
invite the neighbors over and that's
when you all get infected you can ask
Lyle Peterson who is head of the the
group in Fort Collins who got infected
himself playing evening volleyball with
shorts on so I mean it is it's right
there and you're in your neighbor yard
warm temperatures I hopefully shown
enables transmission by increasing the
size of the mosquito population
increasing their their the decreasing
the duration of the gonna trophic cycle
or the number of bytes per time interval
shortening the duration of the extrinsic
incubation period so all this tumbles
upon itself you have more mosquitoes
biting more frequently transmitting
virus earlier in life as it gets warmer
and as we think of climate change we're
going into perhaps a time when this
whole area of permissible habits
temperature regimens are moving north
upslope and the areas like that are
endemic already will have longer
transmission seasons and shorter
overwintering periods so the virus may
be able to pass the winter more
efficiently that way and be just a more
effective problem in the future in my
remaining ten minutes I thought I'd
maybe talk about another virus pretty
quickly because I think it presents an
interesting
a story of an anthropogenic sort of
impact this is an alphavirus that causes
a very bad arthralgia it was discovered
in Africa as well and it it has nothing
to do with chickens it means in this
dialect in Africa it means he who has
bent up because of the very severe
arthralgia causing people to just bend
over because it's so painful it was
discovered during the dengi survey and
dengue acorus used to be breakbone fever
so it's the same really severe
arthralgia that comes with it it emerged
out of Africa and their repeated
outbreaks in Asia during the 60s and the
90s and it sort of disappeared
especially from Asia leading people to
think that the vector 80s egyp d
couldn't maintain it in these urban
environments in that situation in 2004
to 2008 it reemerged and this was doraid
related directly to the expansion of
another asian vector 80s albopictus a
mutation of the virus and perhaps some
climate events that may have helped the
whole thing along the virus has three
lineages one from West Africa another
one from east central Africa and then
there was an asian lineage this is the
current global distribution right now
the virus as i mentioned started in in
and east west africa and then
progressively moved across these aware
there were previous outbreaks in the 50s
that moved into asia and when i was in
the philippines in the 60s we actually
went on a chikungunya outbreaks in
visayan islands in negros oriental in
2004 the virus again emerged move
through the offshore african islands and
into india and from india
into an outbreak in Italy and these
yellow dots are very incomplete but show
some of the places that vironment
travelers have been intercepted so this
is the environment where the virus began
and the trend the canopy of West African
forests then transmitted to humans near
the forest as opposed to when it moves
into the dryer parts of africa where ats
egyp d was considered the vector and
villages that look more like this where
they store water and then you are going
from no longer having a primate
component into a just human human
transmission and then from there it's
into the slums in Africa and again water
storage and 80s egyp d being the most
important component 80s egyp d was moved
around the world just like i had
mentioned the pipiens had during the
sailing error it's an African mosquito
evolved in Africa and was moved
throughout the circum globally
throughout the new world where it was
important in yellow fever and dengue
transmission this is a very very old
out-of-date map this is it's it's very
prevalent in India right now as well so
the 2004 there was some of the things
setting the stages there were a lot of
Indian workers that moved to East Africa
during the British colonial period to
work and manage the railroads so there's
a lot of Indian families that still
communicate back and forth just like we
were talking about West Nile coming from
the Mediterranean the strain being
related to Israel where there's a lot of
families that travel back and forth to
the new new to the New York area there's
an expanded international used tire
trade between Asia and the US and Europe
which is spread a tease albopictus
around the world
economical air travel has allowed
extensive travel between East Africa and
India and humans probably transported
the virus around and there was a
mutation in the virus in East Africa
that seemed to enhance infection in a
tease albopictus and this is the this is
the original distribution of albopictus
an Asian mosquito the red areas are all
the places that was introduced climate
played a very important role in this
because when it was introduced in Texas
it's not by chance that went east and
not West because this species has been
tracking the very humid southeastern
area and this is where it's done this is
where it's done best in areas with high
rainfall as opposed to the West although
recently it's made a toehold in Los
Angeles so when the tires get to be
about this much worn they are no longer
good and have to be recapped and they
throw them into big depositories and
then package them up and send them off
for recapping so they can be reused this
sitting out in the open getting wet is a
great placitas love these to lay eggs in
and they when you package them up like
this you're taking everything that's in
the tire with them also in California we
had the movement of lucky bamboo which
they used to pick in China and put them
in water and in styrofoam boxes and then
put them in big shipping containers and
offload them in LA and that's how we got
our eighties albopictus there from
southern China if you look at the
genetics of the mosquitoes that's where
our center of that's where their origin
seems to be the mutation made it easier
for albopictus to transmit at a lower
dose this is the blood meal tighter data
from Steve Higgs is lab being
transmitted more effectively in a lower
dose but this only seemed to work for
album
and not for Egypt II and the curves for
Egypt he looked just the same
interestingly the virus this is the
another map of the distribution in Kenya
moving to reunion and Mauritius and some
of these offshore islands this is an
interesting curve and shows the
importance I think of air travel and how
these viruses move around the world this
these bars are the numbers of human
cases of chikungunya in France and this
is this is the epidemic curve on reunion
so all these French tourists went to the
island and picked up chikungunya and has
an incubation period they were probably
feeling just fine when they hopped on
the plane they get off they get off in
France and then became sick and these
are the number of cases that just huge
numbers of cases luckily for the French
that at that time I will pick this
wasn't found in France and so far
they've made some interceptions but it
hasn't really become established the
Italians were not so lucky because
albopictus is doing great on the boot
all the way up into the Bologna area and
this is where they had an outbreak of
450 allochthonous cases which they
traced back to one tourists from our
visitor from India this is a map showing
the potential distribution of albopictus
based on AG art model this is
temperature driven but this is areas
where they think that in red that have a
higher probability of getting albopictus
established so with the vector
established over a bigger area if it
were well established in France when all
these people were coming back from
reunion i'm sure the virus would have
had a better time of it in france so
finally this is Los Angeles each of
these little dots is somebody's house
that they found albopictus out and
they've not been able to get rid of it
this is the third summer in a row that
has been there they thought they
eradicated it when they first picked it
up ten years ago they had no reports no
complaints and then three years ago with
lady called up and said you know I'm
getting bit by these little black
mosquitoes could you come and take a
look and and they had we have knowed
abiding little black mosquitoes so the
entomologists from LA ran out there and
they found this area here had quite a
few positives and then they started
doing surveys and found them all over
and pretty well entrenched and they've
had a hundred men marches through these
areas you know dumping pots sanitation
trying to get rid of it and they've not
been successful yet so it's interesting
how you know once these things get
established it's just hard as heck to
get rid of them and once you get a
vector moving into an era it sets the
stage for whatever it can transmit and
then if you have a warming environment
on top of this it really facilitates the
whole picture and it allows these
tropical viruses or even other temperate
viruses a much better chance of coming
in and getting a toehold and creating
really serious health problems and we
did we I like to claim everything yawn
at UC Irvine sequenced this and compared
it to some specimens he got from China
as well as from the previous infestation
and they're all from the same part of
China whether or not our claim to having
eradicated them in the early 2000s is
correct or not we don't know if it's if
they persisted in this neighborhood they
don't have been looking all over the
rest of LA and they don't seem to be
doing well
seemed to be confined to this area and
haven't spread to the rest of LA or
California so some concluding thoughts
humans have changed the planet to
provide space and resources to support
our growing population size expanding
cities are bringing together vectors and
hosts that exploit this niche where
transmission becomes urbanized and I
think more efficient climate warming
enables transmission over an expanding
portion of the earth and movement by
humans and commerce allows for their
rapid transports of hosts vectors and
pathogens amongst these areas and that's
my view of importance of climate change
thank you yes ma'am I'm your two slides
ago when you were showing Los Angeles
there was a red cluster a lot of these
none is there something distinctive
about area well well these are this is I
stole from the entomologist in Los
Angeles and she was planning campaigns
to go door-to-door and she had this area
here where she was wondering if they had
moved into so they were going to survey
these areas and this area they had found
a couple and they wanted to do more
intensive work and these were considered
their hot zones here where they found
more of the positives that's all it
means okay
or if he went there if you went to these
neighbor I went out in there with them
and one walking around down there and
you wouldn't think that albopictus would
do well at all I mean I will pick this
is all over my in-laws properties in the
Philippines and it doesn't look anything
like that I mean these are a lot of
concrete pretty open trailer parks with
not too much green some potted plants
there's a fairly large Hispanic and
Asian population that likes little
potted plants and of course each of them
has a saucer and so that's and buckets
and some people have more vegetated
yards and that's where the adults seem
to congregate so they get this breeding
in a variety of different areas not
necessarily having adults there the
adults go into who's ever backyard has
the most plants because it's more humid
I think what's really containing these
in some degree is the is it's a lot
drier in LA and I think that's probably
not letting them expand out I don't know
why they haven't got in the Arboretum
because they go ahead and dump water all
over that I will pick this bites stuff
other than people so they don't need
people really but they haven't found it
and I they also had a I think somewhere
in here there's like a tire operation
and they went through the whole tires
couldn't find anything in the tires but
they ran a whole bunch of these little
over traps and they and and they also
were looking in people's backyards now
what now what they've been doing is
every every operator has a drill so they
go into backyards if they find anything
holding water they drill a hole that's
that's that's been their primary control
Steve Dobson is thinking of releasing
will ba kia there and to see if that's
going to help but we'll see
John Hughes three or four slide before
this one you showed the geographical
distribution of lville pickles Nick
worldwide and you had orange gospel then
you had two black dog indicating that
albopictus i think was here at here and
one of them was hawaii and then the
other ones maybe in the hook couldn't
tell what stated i believe it gobble
picnic was recorded in peoria illinois
or in that part well those are I won't
take credit from the maps I stole those
from Chet more and Chet I don't I don't
remember the black dots that's why I was
trying to find this day the truth I'm
not doing very well sorry
there haha yes there is I don't know
sorry for all that to say i don't know i
don't know why i don't know exactly
where this is this looks like Michigan
yeah it's pretty high up for because I
know they have a hell of a lot of an
Illinois because Uriel Cutrone did a
whole bunch of studies on them and when
they King into Illinois why this is
black I'm not sure this is this must be
Hawaii here I don't know where this is
I'm not sure okay what viruses have you
isolated notice in California nothing we
haven't tested any we we did go ahead
and develop ok so we do all the testing
for the surveillance program and so in
looking fault not looking forward to in
case something comes in we do have a
multiplex that will test for all the
dengue chikungunya and West Nile in one
assay and then we have a pan dengi
that'll separate out the dengi types but
we don't there's not they've not been
collecting enough adults or had any
linked to disease to warn us testing
them yet so we haven't and that is I
think in one of your slides you showed
in a los angeles-area the distribution
or the prevalence of quickly fosse
agents rather than to our Seles so where
does quinto fasciitis play into well
that is the vector in LA right and so
that our Seles is coming in as well well
I the picture I showed with the bad
swimming pool of the tar Salas that was
in Bakersfield yeah yeah there's a
actually for the pipiens aficionados the
integration of pipiens into the quakes
starts at about Fresno north and that
fresno south and in the southern part of
the state based on some recent
microsatellite work by harry savage
seems to think that those are all quaint
true quaint and they've they're feeding
mostly a little different than they
found in Texas and other places these
feed predominantly on these urban birds
and some dogs and almost no humans well
we we have the same kind of results you
do we looked look very very hard in a
lot of really strange places and they
just these mosquitoes feed on humans
very infrequently but that being said
when we have like a barbecue in the
backyard I'll get bit by tar salas but
when you go out and collect blood and
mosquitoes those those individuals must
be pretty rare us they don't really see
that much oh that's right you should
some slides on your organization present
time and urbanization is going to
accelerate and long for organization if
margins of cities you tend to get slums
or shine
sounds less developed areas and those
great into natural semi natural habitat
you have any information on I don't
think these viruses in United States by
their information elsewhere the patterns
of arbor viral transmission blowing
succession zones and what's going on in
terms of populations well um okay so if
I were to this is speaking and not
knowing okay but we did some studies
back when st. Louis was coming into Los
Angeles and we did neighborhood surveys
and we compared lower socioeconomic
neighbor like blue-collar neighborhoods
with small houses to probably houses
that cost tenfold more and those areas
were heavily vegetated nicely landscaped
more irrigated and they had way more
mosquitoes and then the poorer places
the poor guys were more apt to have bad
swimming pools and junk in the yard and
and Alex the big dog that we wouldn't go
in the backyard anyway but the numbers
of mosquitoes in both traps and that we
could collect or larvae that we could
find were much more abundant in the
heavier landscaped yards so in that
situation it's sort of the better i
think the landscaping and the vegetation
patterns plays an important role and
some of the areas that they were seeing
more st. Louis transmission at that time
was in these higher and neighborhoods
which is why they paid me to do this
because those were the more well-to-do
constituents of the mosquito district in
i've just reviewed a paper not too long
ago from vietnam where they're looking
at je in urban gradients and they're
finding je transmitted in amongst pigs
and urban areas just as high as they are
in rural areas where the mosquitoes from
maybe all from the rice but they
apparently you're flying into town
enough or it's being transmitted by
clinks most people don't think quinces
really good je vectors but something's
all the hit a hundred percent sero
positivity and his urban pigs by the end
of the transmission season not my data
but that's what they reported don't you
and that was st. Louis encephalitis
virus mm-hmm why his st. Louis
encephalitis fire seemingly almost
disappeared in well what what's your
idea I don't have a good all right so I
opened my mouth I opened and so now I
should say something so the it was on it
was undeclared before West Nile came at
least in California and so if you if you
get blamed because you're having
outbreaks you ought to take credit for
having improve mosquito control and
perhaps doing enough pressuring and
mosquito populations to make a
difference so I think that in California
anyway the demise of western equine and
st. Louis which are transmitted by the
same mosquitoes was in part due to
improve mosquito control and better
better operations but when West Nile
came West Nile because of the more
efficient by higher virey mia's and
birds and more effective transmission I
think the entomological thresholds for
transmission are way lower when we had
our outbreak in davis we were getting
huge counts of like three or four
pipiens / gravid trap night and that was
the fit and when you test them you'd get
positive pools out of them whereas
historically if you didn't have hundreds
of mosquitoes in your traps you didn't
really see st. Louis transmission so I
think that played an important role the
other thing is there is
what may have pushed it over the edge is
cross immunity we have one paper where
we did a cross and cross cross immunity
studies in house finches so a house
finch that survives West Nile infection
has sterilizing immunity against st.
Louis but a house finch that well they
all survived same lose but when they get
infected with West Nile on top of that
they will be able to produce a very Mia
sufficient to infect some mosquitoes so
there definitely was an advantage to
West Nile in that cross immunity
situation in house finches I didn't do
it in any other birds so that's all I
know okay we're going to have to
terminate the questions I'm sorry bills
gotta see